the modern little crocodile they're
powerful they're prehistoric yet they're
biosphere is very delicate teaching
locals and teaching tourists about this
type of crocodile is very important for
projects of conservation that amigos
this young man is spearheading and for
ecotourism in Quintana Roo as a whole
amigo Jenkins has been monitoring the
crocodile population Indian camp for the
last 25 years if we understand what's
going on with crocodiles we can
understand a little bit of what's going
on with the ecosystem
we will try to catch the animal either
by hand or with a noose depending on the
position of the animal the size of the
dead moose Council of Canada el vídeo de
sus ojos and we use of us a say that
save Africa con la Luz to keel over as
well and it refers to suppose the es lo
que
prácticamente vamos para no concerns
very similar to how the profiles called
each other sometimes when you do that
the large crocodiles respond sometimes
even the hatchlings the babies start
screaming also
well there was a medium crow coil here
in the middle of the mangrove so I I did
a desperate attempt to catch it so I
jumped into the water
it is frustrating well you know we'll be
better to catch it have any big yes
sometimes you catch it half an hour
after you start sometimes stakes takes
longer
a lot of what I've learned about
crocodiles here in the field I've
learned it from people who used to hunt
crocodiles in the past and then decided
not to hunt anymore and then became the
captains of the boats that work for
conserving croppers so now we have this
morelets crocodile relatively young and
why we know it is immoral that's croc
Allah we know that because a shape of
this note the American crocodile has a
longer and thinner snout while this has
a shorter and wider snout for me it is
very important to teach young experts in
conservation about what I learned here
in the in the field about crocodiles
because when we talk about conservation
we are talking about sustainability with
the help of amigos the same kind and
local stakeholders buying into this
project them realizing that crocodiles
are not just a source of income but it's
a part of their legacy it's a part of
their culture it's the responsibility of
the younger generations the Mayan
culture and the people from abroad that
have made this their home it's their
responsibility to maintain it for future
generations
over the years we have set up over 300
cameras these cameras have generated
over 2,500 photographs of Jaguars under
pressure right now we have probably 3742
Jaguars documented in the region and we
have new ones coming off